tu voi est bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
mauvais on a vu beaucoup de policiers
sur le terrain aujourd'hui des agents de
la faune aussi donc on a l'impression
que comme plus de monde un peu qu'ils
font les recherches sur le terrain les
policiers nous laisse entendre que ils
veulent accompagner aussi certains de
vos citoyens qui veulent aller voir leur
chalet leur dépendance leur roulotte qui
est sûre sur ce territoire là est ce que
ce sont vos citoyens qui ont exprimé une
certaine crainte d'aller faire ses
vérifications là qui justifie et plus de
policiers sur le terrain aujourd'hui non
ses poches au ccif des policiers ça mais
pour être sûr que tout tout tout soir et
c'est partout c'était déjà naturellement
les policiers mènent bien mieux qu'un
déjà son lot mais si les gens sont pas
de leur donner une liste des
propriétaires pour les rejoignent et
déjà d'extérieur qu'on est n 1 ou des
roulottes ou des chats des puits va
d'aller visiter ou au pire elle est
obligée d'ouvrir des portes de force
leurs joints des propriétaires mûri
aussi c'était pour ce qu'ils aient des
propriétaires et aux frères wright pas
se débrouiller tape vais aller visiter
eux-mêmes piraterie de 9,1 ainsi
découvrir des choses dont on comprend
qu'un propriétaire plus à craindre ce
qui va trouver derrière la porte qu'ils
ouvrent dans son chalet donc c'est bien
d'être accompagné par des policiers
aussi le cas échéant
parlez nous de ce territoire là parce
que nous on voit en images on en entend
beaucoup parler ce cadre il à terre dans
lequel les recherches se font ça
ressemble à quoi est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de chaleur est ce que beaucoup
de roulottes scan achats ce qui se fait
là à l'automne cesse sait quel genre de
territoire on voit que c'est un boisé
dans dans cela mais a au delà versa
quelles sont les activités qui se passe
dans ce territoire alors c'est beaucoup
de petit air de petit arbre sur la boîte
oui mais data de cabane à sucre de
boisés aménagé par les propriétaires des
lieux de villégiature si vous voulez
pour se reposer une fin de semaine soit
vers une roulotte dans un chalet ou une
cabane à sucre comme on vient dire c'est
quand même très très très bien
les vins c'est quand même très axé les
légendes et j'ai vu des cabanes à sucre
chez nous deux est capable de comme
exemple cinq semaines et des cabanes à
sucre sont à un kilomètre plus loin et
le dans le bourg par contre les chemins
sont bien aménagés où il y avait un auto
de le boisé entre s'échelonnera sur
elle-même
c'est pas toujours très propres c'était
une friche dubois du département d'état
par les nombreuses populations et aux
citoyens comment ils vivent la situation
actuelle parce que il ya un drame qui
s'y jouer chez vous la mort de deux
fillettes pissas a pressé hier la chasse
à l'homme mont-fuji pied pour essayer de
retrouver martin carpentier
comment vous et vos citoyens vous vivez
ça depuis neuf jours mais là c'est sûr
que le drame initial la mort des
fillettes était épouvantable pour nous
lever pour moi personnellement certaines
toute la population de la province mme
inoue peu plus on sente impliqué tout le
monde aurait aimé cdi que le monde
aurait aimé y trouver ce qui s'est
produit malheureusement maintenant lui
rendu une autre étape
c'est une enquête policière dont qu on
n'est pas certain que si si il ya
beaucoup de stress à y avoir
par contre moi je répète faut quand même
pas dramatiser c'est un monsieur qui est
en fuite
moi je pense que ça faut s'en souvenir
il repose devant nous on ne voyait
n'embauchent pas ce qui va sauver mais
par contre on connaît pas son état
psychologique comme plusieurs ont dit ah
vous initiant puis ça crée un certain
stress et d'honneur partir de novembre
ces duels de crémerie nous pour essayer
d'aider des jets puis on va continuer à
les aider grand chauve est un qui va
continuer la semaine prochaine fils
toujours 24 heures par jour existent
mais en effet son puis on a eu beaucoup
d'appuis des policiers puis de se
choisir un panaché des maisons
spécialisées dans lotbinière puis
présente mais il ya eu des rencontres
présentées cette semaine ya eu des
rencontres de gens qui sont allés voir
nous ou jeunes ou quand je vous prie
rassurer voire départ à la sortie c'est
quand j'oublie rassurer aussi demandé
s'ils avaient besoin d'aidé
on a des équipes de policiers avec des
intervenait qui sont promenés ça fait
quatre jours qui se promènent sur le
terrain aller rencontrer les citoyens
des secteurs les plus concernés pour les
rassurer l'arrêt dé leur demander s'ils
ont besoin d'aidé on a même des gens
oui sont allés les intervenants je
regarde mon pays j'aime ce genre de
d'atténuation des gens qui s'occupent de
ce qu'ils ont fait tous les commerces
qui font tous les commerces de cet
avionneur aujourd'hui ça s'est fait ce
texte est un peu comme ce qu'on peut
aider nous parce que nous on fait pas
partie de l'entente est donc ce que plus
haut metn elle depuis que des petites
filles retrouvées décédées
c'est la fin de la police parlez nous de
la cellule de crise bon vous avez décidé
de mettre sur pied comprenant un service
d aide à la population ça consiste en
quoi
oui on le fait bien honoraire et locales
avec des intervenants qui venait pour
les accueillir puis qui était disponible
pour eux le choix vous est franchement
sa part répondu vous ou moi mon adresse
personnelle les gens sont gênés sur ce
je recommande beaucoup lu et alain sont
gênés c'est un personnes la première
journée en a eu deux personnes la
deuxième journée
ces huit personnes aujourd'hui
introuvable payèrent aussi qu'il ya
personne s'est présentée
fake c'est pour ça que charrie tactique
que je veux cadre pas des employés de la
santé c'est certain autre fait que c'est
réellement le méthane est présente mais
qu'il faut signaler si on a besoin et
drake parce que c'est très très
important de penser à sa stratégie et
est ce que vous sentez votre population
un peu anxieuse
je présume que chez vous à moins que je
me trompe bombard potes on bat pas
toujours les portes est dans les
villages des fois tout le monde se
connaît pire on sent en sécurité ce que
vous sentez que votre population
mais signe ballet porte d'abord puis est
un peu plus anxieuse par les événements
se sait sur tech - deux premiers écoutez
ma porte de tout dans ma coach dans un
rayon personne si je vois bordeaux porte
le soir de mai sommes naturellement des
portes de tours je suis pas déçu moi je
vous en occupez revoir et maintenait ses
bars et même deux jours mené en borne
aux pommes de jma portes de maisons en
bois c'est miss usa se fait à peu près
partout d'ingrandes vienne puis je pense
que ça va être une bonne habitude après
oui ça change et une autre manière de
penser
c'est certain monsieur beauvais bon en
espérant que on trouve une solution
rapidement qu'on trouve martin
carpentier ou qu'on ait au moins une
idée de où il est rendu et que ça puisse
soulager un peu votre population
monsieur wallet merci beaucoup de nous
avons parlé ce soir et bonne fin de
semaine
vous aussi merci beaucoup